it's just it's just something about
Luigi's just a raw sexual it's a rock
charisma
sexual Charisma but it's like something
about it's a you know it's like that
kind of nerdy quiet type that yeah yeah
you got bde yeah
[Music]
do you think you're gonna agree on stuff
disagree
probably agree
probably probably agree agree yeah
Super Mario 64 is the best video game of
all time three two one
yeah no yeah I mean even the first Super
Mario Brothers you just gotta say I mean
the 64. it's not even the first one of
the idea of the thing so you're gonna be
the best yeah and then you're saying
video game of all time of all which
means there's people who would argue
that whether or not it's the it's hard
to pick it's like what's the best song
of all time you know it's like it's
impossible to say but I don't think it's
uh Super Mario 64. what would you say is
the best video game yeah of all time the
last of us has been thrown out there
Tony Hawk's Pro Skater 2. that's pretty
good oh man that was good that was good
that was really good I would say either
the original Legend of Zelda oh that was
such a good game
um Street Fighter 2 oh man the original
Mario Brothers original Mario Brothers
is there yeah and then um that Tony Hawk
yeah Tony Hawks I wasted so many hours
of my life yeah you say wasted it's not
I spent so many hours in my life I waste
I fully wasted mine yeah yeah
but then there's also like you know like
first person shooter games like Call of
Duty that are pretty pretty dope I mean
except it is it's Mario
just on a side note on Mario who do you
think would win in Mario Kart I know
that he would we already did we've done
it we've already been okay but but In
fairness sake I didn't win by a lot I
feel like uh
Jack Black crushed us yes I strongly
agree Jack Black destroyed us he is the
Mario Kart yeah it's the one trick you
get in front Bob and weave zigzag
Serpentine you can't just go straight
yeah we were just kidding we were you
got a zigzag Turtle blasted off Turtle
blasted
Turtle blasted
official that seems like a sexual thing
yeah yeah
um great strongly agree strongly agree
yeah
do some turtle blasting
in three two
yeah come on it's it's different it can
be good yeah it can be good but night's
in it had a great night in yeah we're
showing her age pal yeah oh yeah
what's your ideal night in a great night
in I think it's like a movie and or
board games
uh you know a good dinner kids in bed
early and asleep and sleep through the
whole night a little resistance no yeah
you and Mom should go watch a movie
together yeah yeah yeah you should have
some alone time they're always saying
that I'm constantly yeah all of them
next one could you put them to the
middle please I love the sound effect
Luigi is the more handsome Mario Brother
three two one
I agree I agree
he's like uh you know he's just more
handsome you know yeah I can't I can't
just explain it good bone stress
something happens yeah yeah there's
something about you know pops you know
yeah
structure okay Tula is that why taller's
not more handsome right Chris yeah right
no it's just
something about Luigi's just a raw
sexual it's a raw Charisma
sexual Charisma but it's like something
about it's a you know it's like that
kind of nerdy quiet type thing yeah yeah
you got bde yeah
I would make an excellent plumber three
two one
an excellent plumber
no
I mean in order to be a plumber you have
to Apprentice the trade you'd get into
it if that was my career choice I'd be
excellent I'd love it I'd be just
plumbing plumbing and don't get grossed
out by poop I'd be fine I'd be like
ma'am I got this I'd have all the tools
I have a swift belt sweet van yeah I
just uh
I know myself enough to know like
I'm not gonna be great at it you know
like I'm gonna I'll be fine
you're fine but my heart just won't be
in it no I'm gonna go for it I'm gonna
I'm gonna try to win some Plumbing award
what was your plumbing company be called
on the van oh
um
Pratt's Plumbing is pretty good uh you
know declutter your gutter press
Plumbing
relay pipe
if you're not a plumber what kind of
other job do you think you would be in
like if I'm not a plumber yeah I think I
would just be obviously be a
professional model yeah yeah that's easy
yeah yeah exactly why would you do
anything else yeah when people would
just give you money for being so
handsome duh yeah
Pizza is the best type of takeaway three
two one
no
Pizza is fine but this
I mean yeah
good like good Mexican food like really
good Mexican food
Sushi get some sushi sushi what is
takeaway is that like delivery yeah
sorry um I'm thinking of food You're
Gonna like take home and eat later
yeah if I'm gonna yeah I love pizza okay
I don't want to take I thought I was I
was confused by it well here's the
foreign language
this is I'm from America you should
learn to speak English
dude this is England it's the most
reliable it's the most reliable it's
everything I'm not allowed to have in
one meal why are you allowed to have
cheese and bread
I'm gonna go on record and say you can
have it if you want to buddy you know
what how dare you
enough of this superhero crap yeah have
a slice of pizza so what is it a
delivery then a best type of delivery is
that yeah yeah we'd say delivery yeah
because you know what it has the most
iconic delivery person right the pizza
guy yeah you know what I mean like a
second second only the plumber for uh
adult movie star
that's right that's right you know the
most lampooned the most lampooned the
most ubiquitous in those types of films
yeah or just like a stone teenager yeah
it's like you're Pizza bro
and like if you're a 10 year old kid and
you're stuck home alone you can really
screw at this guy yeah you know what I
mean you can get that you can steal from
this man yeah you could take it from his
livelihood yeah baseball is more
exciting to watch than American football
three yeah you didn't even have to put
American football there I know
baseball fan but is it more exciting to
watch of course of course no it's not
are you fans of age I like both I like
American football I'm a Seahawks fan
Seattle Seahawks that's my team and
they've been good he's a Patriots fan
they beat us in the Super Bowl doesn't
matter
also like the Boston Red Sox but what
are you gonna do yeah yeah what are you
gonna do I'm a New England kid baseball
used to be America's pastime it used to
be but now it's now what football is why
was it baseball Oda as a school yeah
it's older as a sport yeah it's also
it's kind of slow it's a bit slow
they're taking nine hours to play a game
they just passed they're just doing some
new laws yeah some new baseball laws or
you got to do it faster you do or you go
to jail I'd watch that yeah yeah I know
if they're like it's gonna get more
exciting click get in there actually I
think they might
I
know men with clubs I would beat the
person opposite me in an arm wrestle
three two one
one way to find out actually you know
what
I'm gonna disagree because I I blew out
my elbow
I might get you so I couldn't I could
never I'd have to Forfeit I can't arm
wrestle my right arm if we go Lefty I
think I think I could do it no because I
have one elbow left yeah I think I would
have a chance but if we go left here
then yeah I think writing you might you
probably would get me because I I'm
really you had a bad elbow I got a
really bum elbow I can't do this stuff
you got to keep your elbows fit pal yeah
and I didn't I I got the same
um I got the same injury that my
character from Moneyball had after
shooting Moneyball arm wrestling blew my
elbow out I'll never play yeah
yeah your baseball career is ruined I
know dude good thing you love football
bro yeah that's right finally I just
wait for the Seahawks like we need a 43
year old with a yeah five five forty
yeah who can bench press uh who can't
even bench press his own body weight
I know beginning of many many films I
think I think so the ncu the Nintendo
Cinematic Universe we're gonna see them
all you wait okay this is like Iron Man
this is it's just the beginning the
animated Iron Man
yeah yeah I mean sure yeah that'd be
pretty good but it's like you know what
did Iron Man do he he proved that that
you could make movies out of this this
Marvel Cannon and there's there's
Nintendo Canon there's stories to be
told there are stories wait was it
animated
Iron Man no this movie
[Music]
yeah I'm so sorry I was doing all that
oh all that stuff all that all those
Body Work sessions with your Bodywork
coach yeah all the stretching just to
get taller yeah the walk that you
learned the whole life you're gonna have
to unlearn that whole walk yeah the lamp
and the accent the French accent I came
up with not well no like and call it
back Luigi's better looking so you you I
mean yeah yeah he's a good looking he's
a foxy guy yeah
he's just got that it Factor even the
name man yeah Lou
Louise Luigi yeah
[Music]
[Laughter]
you know I always try to steal something
from set
um but then years will pass and I'm like
what the hell is this
I'm like oh that was that thing from
that movie